hey guys this Monday I'm just and I met
an pax is great thanks for asking how
you doing Dan padding a little too hot
what we all kind of did but he's not
here this week and I'm taking notes yeah
deal with it but we have a bunch of
interesting things to tell you about
from Paris games week so let's get into
that
now for a handful of years old Dan has
talked about is how much he wants in you
sucker-punch game like keeping set up
almost every day right now he's not here
and I am so suck it down you don't get
to play it or talk about it or anything
the infamous developer that's the
developer of infamous not developer who
is infamous revealed that they have been
working on their new game for three and
a half years titled ghosts of Tsushima
the open-world game takes place in field
Japan where you play the lone samurai
turned vengeful assassin the game is
arriving on ps4 and marks the first two
new IP for sucker punch in eight years
you can check out the trailer and dev
breakdown video for more info on this
one if you like dance having the best
day of your life because of this news
I'm also super stoked because I will
fall over myself to play a samurai
action game that isn't made by Koh a
tech man next up a new last of his to
trailer is out and you guys seem pretty
divided between the camps of where's
Ellie and this looks awesome but
overwhelmingly I think we're all just
trying not to throw up after watching
everything that happens after the ombré
good god the brutal new trailer shows a
young woman about to be hanged when a
tussle with another hostage stops her
gizzards from being cut out at the last
possible moment
the lead captain instructs that the
other hostage be tortured when she won't
reveal the location of her accomplice
luckily said accomplice helps the girls
out of the sticky situation but it's a
bit of a frying pan into the fire type
deal as the trailer wraps up with the
infested storming in in another video
director Neil druckmann said they've
intentionally focused on showing the
threads of a story that at the moment
has no connection to Ellie's story just
so bad could speculate the [ __ ] out of
it for those itchy to see more of
everyone's favorite hero Naughty Dog has
already confirmed that Ellie is the
primary playable character so there's a
good chance she'll be on the scene again
before too long
and finally if there's one thing that
gave me more emotions than watching that
loss of us 2 trailer it was the
announcement of super monkey 2 here's
everything we know about it the short
but sweet trailer featured the message
of looking to the skies the walls are
shifting once again leading some to
believe that the sequel will trade the
minds and jungles of the first game for
something up in the stratosphere its
belong to create a Derek you later
confirmed that the sequel will arrive
first on ps4 and steam but we'll
probably see it come to other platforms
eventually to sit
Xbox fans no release date has been
mentioned at this stage that's
everything we have time for today but do
let us know what you thought about
today's stories in that comment box
obviously there are way more games that
were announced at Paris games week
especially with Sony so keep an eye out
in Gainsville all the details see you
tomorrow
old Anna's talked about was wanting a
new sucker punch game and the way is no
oh yeah he rings up hallways every day
it's about BA think about